after a year and a half in power the
French president Emmanuel macron is
getting more and more unpopular nothing
he does seems to stop the slide my guest
here in London is the French MP
Alexander Holroyd a member of the
president's our Marche party he has a
seat on the Parliament's Finance
Committee how can the president boost
his image ahead of crucial elections to
the European Parliament next year
[Music]
Alexandr homework welcome to the
conflict zone thank you for having me
you said last year that people voted for
Emmanuel macron because they were fed up
with the two main parties
well they got fed up with him pretty
quickly didn't they I mean he got the
worst slump of any new French leader in
twenty years that was within three
months things haven't improved in fact
the latest polls show him going down and
down why is that
actually that's not exactly accurate the
polls have gone up and I've gone down
again admittedly they're down at the
moment I think that the latest poll this
week by Cantor who leaked shows him
falling a further four points between
September and all absolutely but between
the two they went up and they went down
to the surprise of everyone over the
first summer in September last year only
26% I think there's one element which is
important is I think people voted for
Emmanuel macron for the new party
because they didn't want political
figures who are governing based on polls
and that's why they not only voted to
remain your macaron but they voted for a
crushing majority in parliament and
those are unique elections we want a new
government we want a new present and you
government a new Parliament who's
capable of transforming the country
independently of whether the polls go up
and down I think that one of the
disasters that we've had in last twenty
years is that governments have try and
tell me the polls don't matter they do
matter they show his standing and the
party is getting pretty restless I don't
think we should I don't I mean I just
genuinely don't think that we should do
policymaking with an eye to the polls if
not you will not do anything the idea
that by transforming a country and doing
fundamental reforms your poll will go up
or down shouldn't matter one should do
what is good for the country and I'd
like to do for that one of your
colleagues MP who's a founding member of
our mosh Stanislas Giannini he said a
few weeks ago I'm one of the first to be
irritated and exasperated by the
blunders but how do we bounce back not
by changing direction we need to
reconnect with a very important founding
principle of the party empowering the
people to make change happen
reconnect you're talking about after a
year in the heart having to reconnect
with people because you've lost them
within a year and a half that's pretty
unimpressive
actually studies let's get a knee is not
only one of my colleagues but he is also
one of the candidate to take the lead of
the movement I'm sure you all know he
announced his candidacy the day before
yesterday and I personally support him I
think it's absolutely true
that as we undertaking this profound
transformation of every aspect of the
way France is functioned we need to do a
better job at explaining what we're
doing and what about a better job of
keeping ministers happy I mean for
instance you know you've lost three
ministers in quick succession this was
before the reshuffle among them the
Environment Minister Nicola Lula who
resigned on the radio citing what he
called an accumulation of
disappointments then there was the
interior minister Javad : who walked out
after publicly rebuffing the president's
appeals to stay there not a good sign
public not happy ministers not happy
party not happy actually the vast
majority of the ministers are still in
place we could not you know left it's
true out of a set of disappointments not
only with government policy but also
more generally with how the treta
necessity of this transition the
environment trance transition was going
and it's a very tricky issue listen I
won't deny it the there is at the moment
in France a lot of discontent wit for
instance fuel prices because we've
increased fuel prices with attacks on
fuel prices in line with the carbon with
the carbon commitments of every
presidential candidate but we have to
make a commitment three weeks ago we had
disastrous floods in the South of France
we are having more the climate change is
having more and more impact on the daily
lives of our citizens every day the
policy concerns those might be unpopular
but it is an imperative that we drive
from those the problem for the president
is one of style as much as substance
isn't it the fact is he doesn't seem to
like his own people very much last year
he declared France on governor for that
didn't exactly endear him to the people
and in a similarly unflattering vein he
said the country was a society of
entitlement and privileges France isn't
a reform of all country he said many
have tried and they haven't succeeded
pretty insulting night I just don't mean
that secretary the president
before the the president the president
was elected by a majority of the French
people and his majority and his majority
in parliament as well and we've
undertaken those reforms and we've
actually achieved some of those reforms
that everybody said we're impossible
look at the labor market reform the
first reform or the second reform that
we did when we came into office this was
the reform which was perceived by
everybody as impossible in France a lot
of them were seen as benefiting the rich
weren't they
well we going back to that in a minute
it doesn't help the president does it
when he blames the press the press is
being unfair this is a leaf out of
Donald Trump's playbook isn't it I don't
think it's any fan of Donald Trump's
playbook I'll give you an illustration I
was with the president in Denmark when
he made one of those comments that was
then decried in certain media's and
France on the fact that France was
difficult to reform it was an open forum
he was talking to the French community
abroad and to the Danish community who
was there and present with the Danish
Queen and the Danish Prime Minister and
it was a light-hearted comment which was
not insulting in the least not as if it
had but said by anyone it was taken out
of context and distorted is that is that
is that very important what's important
is that we transform a country what's
important is that we achieve what we
were elected to do to commit me to you
at the same time which the pressroom is
that just on the flimsy excuse that he
could find somewhere more comfortable
with them and then we had in July his
comment we have a press that no longer
seeks the truth no longer seeks the
portrayal as having kicked out the media
of the press room is ludicrous the media
was in a room in the main main palace of
the Aliza who is a small over undersized
palace to host the presidency and
they've been moved literally 20 meters
across the street where a lot of the
presidential staff is as well the press
that lay there later thank you ladies
that is that is just inaccurate as a
portrayal of walk that gesture there is
no symbolic gesture behind it the
brothers took it that way though the
press might have taken it that way but
there is none they are still in the
grounds where all decisions are made we
have a press that no longer seeks the
truth what's he saying that the the it's
just fake news I think he says that the
next thing he's gonna talk about saying
I think he's saying that we have arrived
at a point and actually I think this has
been a problem in most elections in the
past where the media's a lot of people
derive their media sources from
unverified sources on the are online and
actually one of the laws that we pass
aims to curtail that that trend that
phenomenon which is undermining
democracies through in through the
Western world but there is a genuine
distrust in certain institutions
including of the media and I think one
shot one will be blind not to see it
it's always a bit lame when politicians
blame the media for them being unpopular
and say they're being unfair to us and
that's what he did no I think the quote
you quoted from Stannis let's give
Heaney
recognizes that we're completely aware
that we are failing sir that we need to
improve on certain aspects the complaint
among associates past and present seems
to be that even by French standards mr.
macro holds the reins of power very very
tightly a small country of advisers
surrounds him and that's it he doesn't
explain and he doesn't apologize he
doesn't mind admitting that does he I
make absolutely no apology for the
verticality of power he said I am proud
of the choices that are being made and I
hate the process that means you have to
constantly explain the reasoning behind
a decision so much for accountability he
hates that democratic vital democratic
process of actually having to explain
why he does what he does I think I'm
though are you happy I think I think
it's great that you're asking the
question because I'm to some extent the
perfect person to answer because I'm the
representative of what I'm a
representative of the other guy can't
attitude that every law that the
president has pushed for has been
adopted after a 4'o debate in Parliament
has been improved amended depending on
the circuit
majority solid majority ting into
account solid majority into account the
comments of every opposition party if
you look at every law nearly every
single law including the budget there
have been amendments accepted from party
every single opposition party you're
noticing my polish means that as
addressing I am addressing your point
resident takes into account all the
Democratic all the in all the different
parties in Parliament on top of that
every main law that we've adopted has
been preceded by months of consultation
with all different organization this
organization the process of having to
explain he said it is a car in Lapage
who was one of the first well-known
politicians to join the macron campaign
she sees a big gap between what was
promised by president macro and then
what the public got what I quickly found
embarrassing she said is the
contradiction between the botton upper
approach that was promised and sold to
the French and the reality democratic
socialism the Soviet way completely
vertical and also very masculine
in other words macro in the office is
not the person he promised to be before
he got that I honestly I disagree with
that assessment completely and actually
if you take the commitments that we made
the program that we made which manifesto
that we made and you take it line by
line you will see that we are putting in
place precisely what we said we would
put in place a big that is a big
difference from what was done in the
past where things were set during the
campaign and were then not achieved
during the presidency we have committed
to one thing we've written a program
it's articulated precisely what we will
do and we are going for this program and
implementing what the French have voted
to afford what about unemployment it's
one of the highest rates in the
around 9% have been the first priority
there is a very important priority
that's actually an essential priority
most of our program is aimed in part at
challenging that which it's more than a
problem it has been a chronical problem
of France for the last thirty years the
idea that we would undo or they would
redo all this transformation in a year
and a half after 20 years of immobile
ISM is ludicrous
do you take the the payday loan wha for
example the region around not some of
the lowest unemployment rates in France
a nine out of ten of the job offers are
for fixed term contracts three-quarters
of those jobs are for less than a month
and 30% are only for one day and that's
not addressing the problem if you're
saying that we have a structural problem
with unemployment I can't agree more we
have a particular problem in France is
we have a mismatch between the demand
and the skills necessary to fulfill that
demand we actually have 42 to 45 percent
of businesses who agree that there are
tensions on the labor market to recruit
yet in regions where we have
unemployment which sometimes is around
10 50 percent 20 25 percent amongst the
youth that's why we've invested enormous
Lee in a great law for traineeship and
skills mister alright the fear from your
point of view has to be that you're
facing the serious unpopularity of the
president ahead of European elections
next year with marine lepen far-right
party pretty much neck-and-neck with
yours
mr. macro has already warned about a
civil war in Europe between liberal and
illiberal parties but if he can't fight
that battle successfully at home it
won't give him much authority to fight
it in Europe will it he said that there
is an atmosphere which is that akin to a
kind of civil war and I think that it is
true today that divisions across
actually most member states are being
felt more than they were in say the 90s
of the 2000s now the European election
is a European election it's an election
about Europe and where Europe goes my
point is that he is drawn the battle
in Europe liberal democracies against
what he likes to call in liberal
democracies I think they're not winning
are they I think there is a point he's
not he's not winning this battle he's
not winning this battery we look at the
the toothless institutions of the EU
trying to have disciplinary processes
against these two countries and failing
miserably to change their policies in
any way whatsoever actually this is a
battle that Europe is losing now miss
mackerel is fighting a losing battle
now so we are we I think the president
am but also the whole party except that
there is today a growing interest in in
liberal democracies and we think that
part of that is because there is an
assessment made by a lot of our citizens
that our democracy our European Union
our states have been unable to address
some of the daily concerns of their
lives and the only way to address that
issue is to change that in the flesh in
the fact which is why we've proposed a
whole series of changes to the European
Union which is a program for the
European that we will defend in the
European actions with people who doesn't
want your president says we need a
sovereignty that is stronger than just
our own which complements but doesn't
replace it who wants that actually
Viktor Orban in Hungary the poles the
Czechs the Slovaks the Italians they
don't want it actually there weren't any
of them there are two four rules who do
you think is winning the Civil War you
look at the difference between the
support for Italy's leaders at the
moment it's far I'd anti-establishment
government which is running at over 60%
support and how much support is your
president getting in the in the mid 20s
actually you look at the support for the
Europeans you look over you look at the
support for the European Union in Poland
for instance and it's amongst the
highest in Europe in Poland among
citizens so the reflection that because
of a certain government is elected
nationally it reflects the views of
Europe of its citizen is a false one you
look in us to Austria same phenomenon
and secondly there's a lot of aspects of
that program that have been welcomed
will unite Germany by Germany on the
eurozone by by Ireland
it's alright you say that but a new
survey last month of European attitudes
by friends of Europe found that almost
half the respondents believed the EU was
irrelevant 64% were not convinced that
their lives would be any worse without
the EU and in France itself your country
forty-one percent thought life would be
just the same without the EU and only 22
percent thought it would be worse that
is hardly the kind of encouragement for
mr. McConnell's grand grand project that
you're claiming I mean I haven't seen
that Europe that I haven't seen that
poll so I'm not yeah that's not what the
perimeter is but there is there is a
regular poll of Eurobarometer poll about
attitudes and intentions towards the EU
and you will see that in countries which
have governments which have been
relatively hostile to the EU to the
institution's as they stand the
population doesn't always follow there
is a separation between national
politics and European politics they're
not the same thing you're not voting for
the same responsibilities it's very
simple so surely you decide this greater
integration that your president is
pushing for this greater cooperation
there's no there's no market actually if
I'm curious to see but for instance the
the president has offered Tory or
suggested that we should reinforce
frontex
the the border the border agency of
Europe by 10,000 men those kinds of
measures are supported by most people
that we should have a European Asylum
agency they're supported by significant
amount is not supported is the way that
you are treating immigrants at the
moment in April group of UN Human Rights
experts warned about what they called
inhuman conditions for migrants along
your northern coast and increasingly
regressive policies in France that's the
effect of your new immigration law
passed in April isn't it you shorten the
deadlines for asylum applications you
double the time for which illegal
migrants can be detained and you
introduced a one-year prison sentence
for entering France illegally and your
president says he wants a more humane
approach to immigration through these
measures for enlightened end
incidentally by human rights class
including the UN that that is a partisan
reading of the bill we have actually in
France one of those
we have one of the most generous systems
one of the most generous system in terms
of exceeding to citizenship well the
president has said is that we need to
increase efficiency of procedures in
part it in great part to be more human
we have people in France who wait for 10
years to have a decision made on whether
they have a right to asylum claim or not
that's unacceptable which is why in this
budget for instance we're investing much
more in all those different aspects
choosing whether somebody has deciding
making the arbitration whether somebody
has the right to refugee status or not
then investing enormous lis into those
people who have the right to refugee
status so that they can integrate
society much quicker all of this is
articulated not only in that bill but
also in the budget the reality mr.
Holroyd is very different according to
medicine sovereignty air the practice is
to return migrants who cross into France
from Italy including unaccompanied
children with no thought for their
safety or for Frances duty to offer them
protection that is why earlier in the
year the Administrative Tribunal in Nice
ruled these practices illegal and
suspended the refusal of entry decision
against 19 - your courts are having to
do what your government should have done
in the first place which is enforce a
just and fair system for these migrants
particularly the most vulnerable ones
the children your court had to step in
to tell the government this is wrong
your refusal eventually to these people
is illegal
actually that is precisely what we're
doing and that is precisely what that
nor aims to do it's precisely that law
aims way of trying to spin there is just
breaking of the law and breaking there
there is no spin there is a desire to
have more clarity to be able to be more
human and efficient in the treatment of
immigration and that includes more
diversity in those who have a right to
stay in France and ensuring that those
who don't have a right can return to
their home countries European
cooperation and domestic policy both of
which in the European side we're
advocating in the French side we're
investing in
according to methods on frontier between
June 24th and 26th 157 people were
returned to Italy without even the
opportunity to apply for asylum 76 of
them were detained for 14 hours 11
miners were illegally returned to Italy
then escorted once again back to France
by the Italian police these people are
being treated like cattle on your border
and by your authorities that's
absolutely untrue if you look at if you
look at the arriving you should look at
the arrivals in France for instance in
welcome from so we we have in the second
country to welcome those immigrants so
those are facts as well let's move on to
the other contentious subject which of
course is is brexit there seems to have
been a sense in France that this was
really just a British problem and France
could get perhaps some profit out of it
but that's changing now isn't it it's
not just a question of wanting Britain
to suffer although mr. macron suggested
that he thought they should suffer
didn't he
no he said I mean Rex it shows us one
thing it's not easy to access its exit
the European Union not without cost not
without consequences is that false well
he wanted the suggestion is that he
wanted blow to pay that suggestion
imagine if a cop leaving the EU is a
complicated process I don't mean that
anybody on either side of the channel
would deny that would you do know do you
know anybody who would actually say that
the the process of leaving the EU is an
easy one well actually some people in
this country in Britain certainly said
it was an easy one but they've been
proved wrong do you believe in a
last-minute deal the two sides taking it
right down to the wire just to show that
they've extracted all the concessions
I'd like and others I just like to make
a point there is no one including the
president in France who thinks that
brexit is a good thing but there is a
strong feeling in London that the French
wanted maximum uncertainty for as long
as possible
the one thing to try and persuade
British based finance houses into moving
into continental Europe no we've been
very very clear from the from the get-go
about what was important to her
we've just talked about Europe we
consider that the European single market
is the future of our economy we were
very clear there is one key red line
which is any deal cannot undermine that
single market my question was do you
believe in the last-minute deal because
it seems that Monsieur bond EA is
softening some of his positions on
Northern Ireland and on financial
services I think we should do everything
in our power to find a deal I think not
having a deal would be if not disastrous
at least very hurtful for both parties
so I think we should work absolutely
consistently would one objective in head
to find a deal any price and it doesn't
come at the price of undermining the
scenario changing the position of the EU
is softening now isn't it I mean that's
the question for Michel Barnier I'm not
into the negotiations day-to-day I'm a
French parliament owned so this is this
is I I'm not a negotiator for the EU but
what what I've always said and what I
will stick by is that we need to find a
deal absolutely it is the priority and
it it's actually the priority which has
been articulated by the 27 leaders the
council at every step of the way but
that deal can not come at any cost that
deal can't undermine the EU the project
that we've taken 67 years or 60 or 70
years to build you're talking about a
rule-based system I'm talking about a
rule-based system I talking about a
single market which works in one manual
the rules when you feel like it and you
apply them when you also when you feel
like it it's very selective isn't it
it's very Cellino as jean-claude Juncker
said in 2016 when he was giving France a
free pass over one of the budget targets
that it had missed why was he doing that
because it's France he said because it's
fun that's the attitude to rules you
enforce them when you want and you
enforce them very selectively that's
actually that's actually inaccurate if
you look at the Commission's comments on
france's budgets which is I suppose is
what you're talking about 2016 is
accurate no but I mean the the
assessment ways we have a commission who
is supposed to enforce the rules that
Commission on every occasion that has
had to
which is called European semester when
he comments on different budget has
always criticized in the last 10 years
France's budget for our excesses and I
recognize that it's criticized nothing
about it's done nothing about completely
recognized it
I recognize it which is why when we
rules which is select which is why when
we were elected we did in our first
budget every effort to come out of the
excessive decease in this effective
deficit procedure which we have
succeeded in doing so I am absolutely
conscious that in the terms of fiscal
policy the excessive budgets that France
has driven through for the last eight
years have undermined stomachs and the
rules so have for instance the excessive
budgets that Germany had in 2005 or the
excessive trade balance the Germany has
today in the eyes of the Commission and
of the tree tomorrow the Commission does
it Roe does its role it enforces the
treaties if it's at the margin it has a
leeway which is inscribed in the treaty
if it is not at the margin then it must
take action it costs up to the hem
comments on the violations I'd question
whether it actually enforces them the
rules thank you Alexander thank you very
conflict zone thank you very much indeed
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]